next speaker idiot
are you alive yes i'm here
okay okay so um
our last speaker of today uh idia
guzboski
uh india is a research scientist at
google demind
and he's working at the foundation team
so foundation
team winning problems for rl and try to
understand foundational theory for rl
and in india particularly focus on
problem dependent analysis
and how to design learning algorithms in
the setting of batch rl and the setting
of with partial feedback
and also in with non-programmatic models
so
uh india will talk about batch policy
evaluation
with confidence intervals
thank you mandy is a pleasure to be here
um
this talk is is not going to be about
the full-blown
mdps i will step down a little bit this
is going to be about
uh contextual bandits and what what we
care about here
is a conf confidence intervals for
uh contextual bandits in the batch in
the batch setting and non-asymptotic
high probability and this is joint work
with the claire vernad andras
and um and chava
okay let's start from the contextual
bandit model where
we're looking at here uh we will have a
context
space and the probability measure over
context space which is potentially
continuous
uh it's a measurable can it's a
measurable conditions
space we will have a probability kernel
which will give us reward function
given the context over
some finite action space and in this
particular
model we will also assume that the
behavior policy
is known um and
the protocol is the following an agent
observes
a tuple of triples which are context
action
rewards all of them are independently
sampled
um and the agent follows some randomized
uh target policy so
uh the fact that all the elements in the
in the sample are are independent
suggests
that behavior policy is going to be
stationary
so we will not assume that it's produced
by
some banded algorithm but rather that it
is a it is produced by the badge
algorithm trained on the large
or large amount of data and this setting
is uh
is is relevant for example in industrial
applications where you have huge data
sets
um and now what do we care care about
if we if we come up with a new policy we
want to
uh give uh give some estimate
uncertainty estimate for the
value which is defined as uh yeah
in the uh in this sense um
and there are many ways to to do that
and one of the
standard way that that you that you have
heard uh
about before is the importance weighting
importance weights uh importance way
that estimator would
which is an um weighted average uh
of the importance weights and and
rewards rewards are
by the way assumed here to to be bounded
this estimator is unbiased but
unfortunately very often
in practice it suffers high high
variance and
uh it's not hard to see why because
um if you if we if we imagine some
some some disagreeing policies with a
little overlap
uh this will likely result uh
in um distribution of importance weight
is
wishes
tile there are many ways to deal with
the
with variance of uh of estimators
one way one one popular way to patch
this up
from the point of view of uh reducing
reward
reducing various variants but in terms
of rewards
is is doubly robust estimation where we
try to
uh correct for the variance in the
in the rewards through reward modeling
typically it's
fitting this functionita hat
on the held out data sets
regression of rewards
and the focus of this talk is going to
be this self-normalized important
sweating estimator where
um this aforementioned uh
weighted average is is normalized by the
sum of the ways and
practically this often results in
reduction of the variance
uh this is known to be biased however
under some
appropriate assumptions asymptotically
unbiased
uh and the in the intuition why do we
care about this
why the variance might be small
here is is by looking at this uh
this small neat inequality which which
comes from the
efferent stains inequality uh
it essentially it can be represent the
the and it tells us that the variance is
controlled by the sum of the
squared way at the reciprocal of the sum
of the squared weights and the square
of the sum what does it actually mean um
it
it means that in some cases um
depending on the on the way on the
distribution on the distribution of the
weight
we might go uh we might capture
different regimes
of the of the behavior of the of the
estimator for example
if two if two if two policies are
perfectly aligned um are identical
this will be of order one over n if
they're completely
non-overlapping uh we will approach
one and uh all the intermediate behavior
is is captured by this quantity which
in monte carlo theory is is called
effective sample size
now uh in in a sense this is uh
this is a nice um instance dependent
quantity
which we would like to depend
on in our analysis and which
uh and which has to be and
which ideally has to be evaluated from
data
now a little at little um
idea on how on how the estimation of the
of the value might look like here and
and to recap
what what we're after we're after the um
high probability a high probability
lower bounds on the value
um where we assume epsilon to be
small and and data dependent our
confidence interval small and data
dependent
and it and the usual analysis undergoes
three um
and the usual analysis undergoes
decomposition
into the uh three parts here
uh we will get rid of the randomness in
the context by
separating the concentration of the
context
we will look at the bias of the
estimator and the concentration of the
of the estimator and uh for now
i will focus only at the concentration
of the estimator because this is
this seems to be the most challenging
part
um for for this type of confidence
estimation and the dependence on the
variance
or on the on on this kind of quantity
that we that we that we would like our
confidence bound to
depends on will come precisely from
from from the analysis of the
concentration of the estimate
uh to be more precise
on on what do i mean i mean here i'll
make a brief
a brief recap of of what is
concentration
and why the standard tools uh
with the with with dealing of dealing
with the concentration are not enough so
uh whenever we have a sample of
independent random variables
uh sampled from the same probability
measure
uh in the consideration we care about
how a fixed measurable function of this
of the sample
deviates from from its mean and the
understanding how it happens comes from
from the analysis of the tail
probability
it's a pretty standard it's a pretty
standard thing
um one one of the classic
concentration inequalities as an example
is a markov and the workhorse of the
of the computer science and statistics
are herding and
understands inequality which essentially
work for
sums of independent random variables
where where
random variables have a subgaussian
behavior
uh or in practice typically assuming
that
random variables are bounded however if
we will go back
quickly and look at at what are the
requirements in in
stating our confidence our confidence
interval we quickly observe that
things things depend on unbounded random
variables
such as the importance weights note
that that the behavior policy might
might be arbitrarily close to zero
um and this effectively excludes things
it excludes the use of standard tools if
we want to do things really cleanly uh
of course we we can introduce all all
kind of tricks
and hacks for example truncation of the
of the importance weights was a
is a is a pretty it is a pretty popular
tool in the literature but
it has its own limitations we introduce
truncation we
introduce additional bias in the
estimator
which we have to control for and this
results in
some hyper parameter tuning um
and we would like to to avoid that
variance
is important our bounds should depend on
the variance as
as we saw before in case of importance
uh self-normalized importance weighting
it it's uh
it's essential because we hope to
capture this
small variance which appears often in
practice
um sometimes estimator is simply not a
sum
like in the case of self normal less
important sampling we have a self
self normalization which introduces
dependencies
um right so so this is uh briefly
uh to have a picture of um of the same
challenges but in the context of the
self-normalized estimator
and if if if i would revisit the
concentration the toolbox of
concentration inequalities that are
available to us the first
thing uh which which would be possibly
an answer
to to that are the bounded difference
methods which try to
look at the concentration of arbitrary
functions of arbitrary measurable
functions in terms of their sensitivity
to small
perturbations what do i mean by this
imagine that we
have the original sample uh and i
resample one of the elements freshly
from the same distribution and what i
want to say at the end that
at the end at the end this this function
is not
sensitive to this to this kind of
resamplings
and this and this and this is at heart
of the classic again
at the classic reference stance
inequality where where the variance
intuitively it's it's also pretty clear
intuitively that that the variance
is controlled by uh some or
in this case expect expected sum
of the uh squared perturbations of that
function so
ideally we would like to get confidence
interval which depends on something like
like this without in introducing much
more of
uh additional assumptions uh
again a standard tool in the is about
the difference in equality here
or macdiarmid's inequality where we
again look at the
efferent stains variance proxy we
capture some
perturbations of the functions of the
of the function at hand uh and
we quickly observed that the inequality
is quite pessimistic because
we do that uh in terms of the supreme
over all the samples and that supreme
over
that that supremum of the of the
variance proxy gives us the rate
um clearly this is not always uh
enough because um recall that
that that that essentially our in our
importance weights are unbounded and
maybe we we also want to
capture variance so it doesn't seem to
be
the tool uh that we would like to use at
the end of the day
now uh
that's that's that's that's right
neglect information about higher order
moments
uh and the answer to that could be a
more powerful tool
like recent recent developments in
in concentration inequality um
which gives us this uh beautiful
exponential version of
french states inequality which basically
tells us that to control
the deviation of the of the function
from its mean or the
or the moment generating function we can
control it
in terms of the moment generating
function of the efferent strain variance
proxy
so and that seems seems to be sufficient
recall that
um chernoff bound would immediately give
us
concentration inequality if we if we
were able to
uh control the tails
of the uh efferent stain efferent stain
variants proxy
now um this is a bit challenging to use
at
times can we get something more
user-friendly where where we can plug in
our estimator and get concentration
bound that
that we want uh indeed by
by by going through standard control
of the of the moment generating function
of the
of this of this thing which is a french
10 variance proxy we can get something
like that which indeed will depend on
on the uh efference 10 proxy
plus some some terms which come
from from from the control i just
mentioned
and this is uh upgraded
it's um um it's a it's more
sophisticated version of the
uh macd inequality because now instead
of controlling
first order bound the difference we
control we need to
control in some way second order bounded
differences
through through this uh scary looking
inequality
and again we we encounter su premium of
supremum over samples so
it suggests that this this this might be
a bit challenging if we want to get
something
uh instance dependent that depends on
the distribution of the
of the importance weights um so this
this constants in practice would
would have to be data dependent uh and
typically
we would need in one or another way
boundedness of the
of the random variables to achieve that
can we do something even more
user-friendly well uh
it turns that it turns out that we can
uh if we consider slightly different
version of uh
of the of the african variance proxy uh
in the following form it's
semi-empirical proxy which
uh it is semi empirical because we have
this
um conditional expectations in the
summation
so it partly depends on the distribution
and partly on the data
but the trick of the
eventual use of of this would be to get
to get uh to get out
to get away from the parts of the
distribution that we don't have
control over and and leave with um
something that we can do with the
expectations that we can actually
compute and
these are this allows us to prove this
concentration inequality which is
surprisingly
uh light on assumptions so the function
here
has to be has as only it
needs to be measurable we do not
explicitly control
um control the detail of the
of the of the function of the sample
but the control is is is implicit
in the in this variance proxy so
whenever we
whenever we want to control particular
function at hand we need to
control this um semi-empirical quantity
right and and uh indeed using uh we
under making more assumptions we can
recover
the uh standard forms of bernstein's
inequality and whatnot
um now uh how how does it
what what can we do in terms of the
value of the and
of the uncertainty estimation here a
value bounds for
again for for our weighted uh for our
self-normalized importance weighting
uh and it turns out that we can prove
the following it looks it looks a bit
scary at the first side but i will go
through all the
uh all the terms um
and the first thing to note here is that
these
this depends on these efferent variants
proxy of the self-normalized estimator
and the bias and both are
data dependent and both are computable
even though they involve expectations
note that we have conditioning
on the on the context so we don't need
to know distribution of context
we don't need to know distribution of
rewards uh
the only need the only thing we need to
know is is the distribution of the
weights
but it is known to us because we have
assumed that
that the behavior policy is known now
computationally this might be a bit
challenging
uh even for a finite even for finite
um action spaces but
at the end of the day we can approximate
this
using monte carlo simulation and and as
you will see in them
in the numerical experiments this works
pretty well
uh now if you look closer at the
variance proxy
it is indeed very similar to what i was
talking about
uh at the beginning of the talk um
indeed
it is it is uh it it captures the
uh effective sample size
of the self-normalized estimator
and through this through this bound
we can have all kind of different
regimes
depending on the overlap um
between between target and behavior
policy without
making any explicit assumption about
overlap
and the note and no truncation is
necessary uh
the bias term is is a bit trickier to
um come to to come by but uh the
the main message behind it is that it's
a multiplicative bias
and it approaches one for for for easy
distributions
for uh for this for distributions which
are not skewed
and therefore this bound becomes tighter
and tighter now the
um finally there is a term which
which uh comes from the control of the
of the context but it's just uh
um is just a herding's inequality
because uh value in our case is bounded
because
rewards are bounded this is pretty easy
to see from the
from the analysis
right and um so
yes this i already mentioned so how does
it work in practice even though it it
looks a bit hard and not and not
interpretable
everything is slightly harder to to
interpret compared to more pessimistic
bounds
but uh how does it work numerically well
imagine this uh
first synthetic simulation where where
we are giving
um two policies and the means to
control of their misalignment these are
effectively gibbs policies which are uh
focused
on two different actions and how
temperature will will control the degree
of the
of the of the misalignment
and uh comparing to to bounds which to
confidence intervals which uh use
truncation of the weights
um we can see that even for
for relatively large sample size we can
always
come up with a higher degree of of
misalignment where
where truncation will will fail but
uh the data dependent nature of this
efferent state bound allows us to still
uh
recover to to still estimate value
reasonably well
uh so the the value is a dashed line
we have a sample size and the and the
convergence
uh to the value where the efferent stay
inbound is the
is the one on the top um now what about
the
more realistic cases well uh
yes so it's a another view on the
on the coverage of the bound we can do
the same
um so but instead of instead of varying
the
sample size we can we can vary error
probability and look at the different
standard tools with the truncation
standard balance with truncation and we
see that
efferent stained bone becomes somehow
numerically
closer to the to the actual value
sooner for this smaller
error probability um
now what we largely care about care
about
uh in the in practice and
which of policy evaluation
can can be very good tool for is of
policy selection
so i'm given i'm given data set and the
finite set of
of candidate policies uh how do i select
the best action based on some estimator
and the estimator
uh here is a in the
is it is in the colloquial sense so
estimator can
can be uh confidence bound i
pick is a rule for for selecting my uh
target policy so it it can be also
thought of a
light as a lightweight version of
of policy optimization where the uh
class
of policies is finite um
again let's let's let's let's look at
the
at some non-synthetic experiments in
this case where the
setup is uh is very simple we have ideal
policies
and two policies which are fitted on the
data
using uh gradient descent
with respect in in the first case with
respect to
uh by maximizing the value with respect
to
importance where the estimator and the
second one is
with respect to self-normalized
estimator
um just just like shown
shown here and the goal is to see
whether
a confidence interval would will allow
us to
deal with overfitting which is induced
well
perfect fitting which is induced by by
these estimators
and and whether other um
other estimators side
side such as the ones rules such as the
ones which
do not use confidence intervals which
will actually fail uh even though
our target policy is stochastic
we pick rather small small temperatures
so
so that it becomes almost deterministic
to
have some idea on on on more realistic
setting because
in practice policies uh banded policies
um in in recommender systems for example
are are often deterministic um
and indeed for the sample for the small
sample size
we we quite often see that um
many bounds which rely on truncation or
non-hyperability bounds are vacuous and
decision cannot be made reliably or
they go for a sub-optimal policy where
is
more data-driven um efferent stain
efferent stain type bound um with
respect to self-normalized
estimator performs really well
and as expected as sample size increases
they all catch up and we are able to uh
really to
select ideal policy in all cases but
again as we saw from from the synthetic
from the synthetic
experiment even for a very large sample
size
you can come up with a problem where the
overlap is
is really low and then um
many of this of this can fail uh
even for uh large sample size now
uh i have couple of minutes i can um
i could i guess i could briefly um
revisit the proof go
go for the proof of the inequality and
just briefly mention some
some techniques which are used here uh
as i mentioned before concentration of
context is just herding's inequality uh
by uh by by observing that that
that the value is bounded and we have to
deal with
some of independent uh random variables
uh the bias the control of the bias
is is rather interesting here
because rather than saying something
asymptotic
we go for a non-asymptotic version of it
we use uh this uh association inequality
which is
uh which is known as harris inequality
which
simply says that we can control the um
the
x the x the expectation of product of
some
sums of of random variables if if there
is a core
if there is a if there is a
non-increasing and non-decreasing
coordinate wise behavior in each
function we can split that
and in the itself normalized uh
estimator is one of those cases where
uh you you can actually do that and then
and then we effectively split it into
important sueded estimator
uh which we know is unbiased
and the multiplicative bias which which
which will be governed by the
uh by how skewed the this the
distribution of the weights will be
again
this this this can be computed from data
because
uh distributions of the distributions of
the weights
the distribution of the weights is known
now as the proof for the main
concentration inequality
uh these realize uh this draws
these draws heavily on the uh on the
standard analysis of the mach diabetes
inequality
and the pre and the analysis and the
proof of the
efferent stains inequality uh with
a bit of self of self normalization
so um unlike unlike the case
so so so essentially to prove to prove
everything here
we need to prove uh
we need to prove that the function and
it's that the
the function of of interest and its
efferent stains variance proxy
form a canonical pair as it is known in
the self in the self normalization
theory and then we pretty much can use
the
standard results um of the penny and
others
to arrive at the concentration
inequality uh that
that we use here and the yeah and the
beat
and the beat and the interesting bit is
how do you do that
well it turns out that this standard
duke martingale does the trick
um and and this is a and this is really
similar argument of how
uh efferent stains and equal the proof
of the efferent strains inequality goes
through uh and uh yeah i would like to
conclude with some that
take home message so this this seems to
be numerically
non-vacuous for for the value estimation
in contextual bandits this is for the
self-normalized
estimator which is known to be uh which
is known to have a low variance in
practice
and it seems that these bounds really
are able to capture
this fact and might be useful for a
practical
uh confidence bounds non
asymptotic high probability ones
and the sum and some challenges this of
course
limitation is that we need to know
behavior policy
um it has to be static so for example
behavior policy
cannot be generated by the bandit
algorithm that we run in the past
and um an obvious
interesting extension of this is of
policy optimization
um and and there is some some
some work that we are tried that we were
trying to explore
in the pack based setting by having some
uniformity over uh over policy class
well in this case in the tag-based case
over the
over the probability measures over the
uni over the classes
over the policy classes and uh
yeah i believe that's it and thanks
uh thank you idia for the beautiful
analysis uh so i
have a one question for clarification so
since
data analysis is really for the tabular
action
case is my understanding correct it's a
finite
it is a finite action case but the
context
but context doesn't but the context
space doesn't have to be
finite of course of course and
is is there any like notion of
optimality for the confidence
intervals uh
no it's uh there is no we
don't have bounds which which would show
that that this is optimal
but we just just rely on some on some
numerical
uh evaluation for that yeah but like
numerically like does the confidence
bounce
give you some something like some
asymptotic convergence in probability
to the right interval is there something
like that that can potentially be proved
um i think this can be explored but i'm
i'm
i cannot uh say on the spot if this
if this has this optimality
and also if the policy is not known and
then
the weights are not known right so in
that case
if we want to get similar similarly
tight error bonds
doesn't mean that we need to estimate
the policy to the extent that
all the all the numerical values have to
concentrate
very nicely so
a lot yeah we would need to to have
something tied
um we would need to have control of the
of the approximation of the
approximation of the behavior policy
reasonably well yeah and uh it it
it feels to me that that it will defeat
the purpose of the entire bond if you
would do
a really pessimistic analysis of that so
so i guess
i i guess one one of the challenges
would be to control this
approximation error by um
with the similar data dependent uh
attitude
right right and also so i
i think also i got lost so what was the
final assumption that we needed
the final assumption on the
concentration uh the
demonstration bond so
the uh let me go
go back to it write this one right so
the function f
uh has to be measurable and uh that's
pretty much it
right and this and this um and this is
the bound which
which holds with respect to free
parameter right
so uh ideally you would like to tune it
in some in some way but apart from
independence is crucial here
uh but apart from from that there are no
assumptions
okay so we we really just need v to be
well-defined
right right so in the standard in the
standard concentration
uh you typically make assumptions during
the
analysis of the moment generating
function right
and here and here this is this is
deferred
to to the analysis of this v
so it's it's up to user of the
concentration bound
uh how to how to bound this v
so and and we don't make this decision
during the the analysis of the
of the moment generating function yeah
very nice
i think gregory has a question in the
chat
can you see it in the in the q a but
just
just a second yeah could you
so so about the term the term okay let
me
yes i see um let me share
let me share my screen again and go back
to
uh to the point
right so so so the question was about
this this term right um
and this and this is so so we can see
that
this term is uh
[Music]
it's um it's known to us
it's a part of the it's a part of the
data set we
condition on it and this term is is not
known but it's distributed according
to to the same distribution as wk
right and this is not known and we need
to come to compute
expectation and we and we effectively
compute expectation with respect to
to this um and
this is um yeah i believe that
a similar version of this kind of
inequality can
it can be shown where instead of the
replacement because here
we have a replacement right so so if you
if you think about the variance proxy
here we have a
replacement of the element in the in the
sample
a similar version i think can be shown
for
deletion um but then again
this will not make concentration
inequality uh completely empirical
because we will depend um
we will will have conditional
expectation only with respect to
w from one to k and all the remaining
ones
uh and we would compute expectations
with respect to all the remaining ones
right um and i think
yeah this second part of the question
was
uh could there be a fully empirical
version
a fully a fully empirical version uh
would be the one without this
expectation
here uh and i looked
i mean i tried to look really hard off
into it and my and my
understanding was that this is i'm not
i don't know how to do it but
clearly something like that is possible
if we
if if we make further assumptions on the
bondedness like
we can get we can get empirical bench
stains inequality
and um similar bounded differences
inequalities
with some with some proxy with some some
variance proxies are also
um are also known
also known i think works of andreas
maurer
but um yeah i think we would need to
give up something and assume more to get
to get fully empirical version and
did you test
yeah i mean um a
very issue yeah i'm not aware of any uh
i don't know
of any ways how to do this fully
empirically so
yeah no no experiments on that part
thank you do we have any more questions
for idia
or for diana
is there anything you want to add
okay sean is walking to us
i have to turn off my mute button no i
mean only that i
i'm looking forward to studying this and
there's a lot of beautiful techniques
here that's all i can
i don't have any questions right now um
great okay so uh we're going to conclude
here
and we're going to see you again
tomorrow so the gathering time will
start at 8 30 and talks will start at 9
00
at 9 00 a.m pacific time and thank you
to
all the speakers thank you
alright see you tomorrow